♪ ♪ ♪
♪ D'abord j'ai eu très peur ♪
- Cette chanson, "Jeururvivrai"
de Michèle Richard, a accompagné
Linda Grondin durant Noël.
Pour la première fois de sa vie,
elle a passé les Fêtes
sans domicile fixe et
loin de sa famille.
LINDA GRONDIN, résidente,
Pavillon Patricia Mackenzie
- J'espère que c'est le dernier.
- Elle a malgré tout trouvé
fafafamille temporaire.
Tout au long du mois de
décembre, le Pavillon Patricia
Mackenzie de la Mission Old
Brewery a organisé des activités
festives, comm s s spectacle
d'un imitateur d'Elvis.
- Il était très bon,
c'était le fun. On a eu bien
du plaisir. Moi, je connais
toutes lhahahansons d'Elvis.
- Les services pour femmes
sans-abris ont hébergé plus
d'une cinquantaine de femmes
dans les dernières semaines.
ELYSABETH GARANT, serv. clin.
aux femmes, Mission Old Brewery
- On est tout le temps,
tout le temps, tout le temps
complet, là.
- Elysh h h travaille
depuis une quinzaine d'années
auprès des femmes en situation
d'itinérance.
Pour l'intervenante,
le temps des Fêtes,
il se célèbre avec elles.
- J'ai toujours travaillé
les journées de Noël,
les journées du jour de l'An,
parce que... pour moi,
c'est important d'être présente
puis il y a quelque chose
d'effectivement magique qui...
s'explique pas vraiment, là,
qu'il faut vivre pour
comprendre.
- Les employés ont bénéficié
d'une aide précieuse.
Halte-chaleur qui est ici.
- C'est ça, Café Mission Keurig.
- Au coin du boulevard Saint-
Laurent et de la rue Clark,
plus de 125 bénévoles
ont contribué aux célébrations
de Noël.
MARIE-PIER THERRIEN, dir. des
comm., Mission Old Brewery
- On a eu des groupes, des
familles, plus de 75 personnes
qui sont venues servir
les repas. Puis, en plus de ça,
on a eu environ une
cinquantaine de bénévoles
qui sont venus faire diverses
tâches connexes, autant
à nos pavillons pour femmes
que nos pavillons pour hommes.
- i,i,i,i,i, les services
d'hébergement affichent complet
et les gens se tournent
vers les services d'urgence.
- On parle de plus de
1000 personnes qui ont visité
nos refuges d'urgence.
- Ce nombre devrait continuer
d'augmenter avec l'arrivée
des temps froids. En attendant,
Linda Grondin travaille
activement pour se retrouver
un logement et laisser sa place.
- J'ai hâte. Pas que je suis pas
bien, là, je suis bien, mais
j' d d d d d'être toute seule.
- Et si elle se décourage,
elle aura toujours une chanson
pour l'inciter à continuer
d'avancer.
- "I will survive".
- En français.
- En français, naturellement.
- ♪ Oh non pas moi
♪ Je survivrai ♪
- Ici Alexis Tremblay,
Radio-Canada, à Montréa